the perfect onscreen kiss and how to do
it whoa I've had bad bad kissers that
didn't really know the rules so we're
asking about how to do an onscreen kiss
and how to do it right yeah you want to
know that you want other tricks
yes all right no eye contact you have to
relax not too much tongue
all tongue no lips you have to pretend
that it's someone you really want to
make out with so you're kind of just
like like a it I call it the fish it's
like I look terrible you know how it
works just I try to open my mouth as
wide as I can and try to swallow their
whole face don't swallow the other
person's face mostly lips with some
imagined tongue involved not so much
tongue but most people don't do the
tongue so I think you're not supposed to
but I'm learning that I'm all for a
little bit of tongue why not
usually I just eat like a lot of garlic
or onions before the kiss I think
there's a difference between like actual
kissing and on-screen kissing you have
to make it a little less pornographic so
don't make it look real grab his face
and like lick it
I'm sure that look to relate here it's
better if you like them for sure it's
way better just kind of go for it just
go for it you just gotta go for it it's
pretty much that I take that easy
why do you think more people don't use
tongue maybe for health reasons sanitary
conditions yeah that guy like son